why did you guys did you want to do
another one it was so massive
this is funny because it was we when we
never intended to do another one
and i feel we were both being really
like we dug our heels in when they were
like we're going to do a sequel and
john always intended for it to be just a
standalone movie with a slight open
ending and
it didn't necessarily need to lead to
something else so i think we were being
really stupid to be honest like i think
we were just like no
no being too precious about it yeah and
then i think there was this genuine
demand and sort of an investment in the
family and what happens to them
and what the heck is she going to do
with a newborn baby in this world and i
think
all of a sudden john was pitched a bunch
of ideas
and he was going to oversee the next one
and then he all of a sudden
he goes all right i just have an idea
and he pitched me the opening
yeah and i was in like it was just
he's very creative that way very clever
yeah i was like it's
and i think it's i i get what you mean
by its precious one thing that it came
out
but at the same time when it's so
massive like when
everyone's such a fan of it it's really
cool to like give people that next
you know yeah it's definitely when you
guys see it it it is an
extraordinary sequel and and i think he
really did the impossible because it's
sort of a tall order to try and
do the first one and when the first ones
had this sort of meteoric life
that you have to try and match it in
some ways and
it's really cool it's like a really cool
movie want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure